intel was facing the biggest crisis in
its history from what looked like a
dominant position of strength its Rivals
had surpassed it technologically its
margins and market share had been eroded
to almost nothing and its leaders were
struggling to turn things around if you
think I'm talking about 2022 I'm not
this symbol outside it's with Intel the
computer inside this was the mid-80s and
intel was on its knees yet by the turn
of the century it had not only survived
it became one of the most successful
companies in history today a deep dive
into one of the most amazing comeback
stories of all time and the man who made
it happen to do justice to such an epic
story you need to go back to the
beginning and a guy named Bill Shockley
foreign
people in the history of Technology
trained as a physicist he worked at Bell
labs and was instrumental in early
semiconductor research during World War
II he conducted secret Research into
radar techniques to help the Allied war
effort Shockley became so integral that
the American government asked him to
prepare a report on the number of
probable casualties from an Allied
invasion of the Japanese Mainland his
findings influenced the decision to drop
nuclear bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
after the war Shockley returned to Bell
Labs there he was at the heart of the
most important invention in the history
of Technology the transistor early
electronic research in the field of
transistors gave promise of new
developments that would revolutionize
Communications equipment as well as
control systems for rockets and guided
missiles in 1948 Shockley along with his
colleagues John bardeen and Walter
Bratton applied for a patent for a
germanium transfer resistance unit
Shockley continued his research often in
secret he considered his colleagues his
fiercest competitors in 1950 Shockley
released a 558-page book titled
electrons and holes in semiconductors it
would become a Bible for scientists
working to develop new variants of the
transistor and other devices based on
semiconductors by this stage he was
generally regarded as the sole inventor
of the transistor which put further
strain on his already tense relationship
with his colleagues bardeen and Bratton
believing he wasn't receiving enough
recognition for his work and having
fallen out with almost everyone he
worked with Bill Shockley decided he
needed a change so he left Bell Labs he
spent a semester at Caltech and then a
year working for the government in
Washington DC but nothing fully
satisfied him Shockley believed he was
more capable than anyone else so he
figured why not do things his way why
not start a company Shockley flew to La
where he met with Arnold Beckman a
chemist and businessman the pair
discussed the idea of a new lab that
would build cutting-edge semiconductor
devices at a lavish lunch in February of
1956 Shockley and Beckman announced that
their semiconductor lab was open for
business Beckman wanted Shockley to
establish his lab in Southern California
near his own company Shockley as ever
trusted his own judgment he thought
Mountain View was a better location for
one thing as the head of Stanford
explained it would be highly beneficial
for Shockley semiconductor and for
Stanford to be close together the other
reason Shockley chose Mountain View was
to be close to his mother in Palo Alto
it's kind of crazy to think that one of
the reasons that Silicon Valley became
this massive Tech Hub is all because
Bill Shockley wanted his office to be
close to his mom today the original
location of Shockley semiconductor 391
San Antonio Road is so famous that Mark
Zuckerberg built a meta office there the
address has even lent its name to a
documentary about the history of the
semiconductor industry that was February
of 1956. in December bill Shockley would
be awarded the Nobel Prize in physics
for his work inventing the transistor he
would share it grudgingly with his
former colleagues Walter Bratton and
John bardeen but at the same time the
Nobel committee was deliberating about
who to award the prize to 6 000 miles
away Soviet tanks were rolling into
hungary's Capital Budapest they had been
called in by hungary's puppet regime to
crush a popular Uprising in protest to
the Soviet Union's heavy-handed rule
over Hungary a delegation of students
had broken into the main building of a
local radio station where they broadcast
their 16 demands for political and
economic reform they were detained by
armed guards and when protesters
demanded that the students be released
police responded with bullets this was
the spark that Lit the Hungarian
Revolution thousands of normal people
organized into militias to fight against
the authorities in an effort to quell
the violence the Hungarian government
withdrew from the soviet-aligned Warsaw
Pact and pledged to reinstate free
elections by the end of October 1956
violence had subsided the protesters had
won or so they thought orders were
received from Moscow the Crackdown was
to be Swift and brutal children join
their parents in the streets to fight
the Soviets it didn't make a difference
though by the middle of November the
authorities had killed more than 2 500
protesters and extinguished the flame of
Revolution 200 000 hungarians fled most
escaped through holes in the Iron
Curtain to Austria one of the hungarians
who successfully made it across the
border was a 20 year old chemistry
student named Andros East Von growth
Andross didn't know it at the time but
he would go on to become the most
important person in the history of Intel
by 1956 Andros had made it to New York
where he was taken in by extended family
he was safe but he had already lived
through enough tragedy and turmoil to
last a hundred lifetimes eager to leave
his past behind him Andross decided to
change his name so that it would be
easier for his professors to pronounce
Andros isvan Grove became Andrew Stephen
Grove Andy for short he won a
scholarship to study chemical
engineering at the City College of New
York Andy's English wasn't great so he
had to repeat each day's work again
every night with a dictionary by his
side despite these challenges he still
graduated at the top of his class this
was such a big achievement that the New
York Times even wrote a story about it
after graduating he moved to the other
side of the United States where he
obtained a PhD in chemical engineering
from Berkeley let's leave Andy for a
moment and go 500 miles down the road to
Mountain View Bill Shockley had just
founded Shockley semiconductor remember
how earlier I said that despite his
undeniable Brilliance Bill Shockley was
one of the most notorious figures in the
history of Technology yeah that's
underselling it shockley's own
biographer someone you'd figure would be
sympathetic to him said that he may have
been the worst manager in the history of
electronics Bill Shockley was a tyrant
despite having some of the smartest
people in the country at his disposal
his egomania meant he didn't trust them
with anything he was impossible to
please and increasingly paranoid once
after a secretary suffered a small cut
Shockley demanded all his staff take lie
detector tests so he could find the
culprit it didn't take long for people
to begin looking for the a door in late
1957 less than a year after Shockley
received his Nobel Prize a group of
eight of the lab's best researchers
decided that they'd had enough they
walked out of the lab and straight into
history one of the young men Eugene
Kleiner wrote to a connection at a New
York investment firm he wrote seeking
assistance kleiner's contact wasn't
really interested he was about to retire
and he didn't want to manage an entirely
new portfolio so he passed the letter to
a young associate named Arthur rock this
is an amazing sliding doors moment in
history Arthur Rock knew about
semiconductors and understood their
potential he also knew all about Bill
Shockley both the good and the bad and
he understood what a big deal it was
that these eight guys were willing to
quit working with a man that many people
in the industry referred to Simply as
God so Arthur Rock wrote to Eugene
Kleiner an over dinner in San Francisco
suggested an idea that even these
Geniuses never contemplated he told them
that they should start their own company
it was the best way for them to gain the
autonomy they craved while also
capturing a fair share of the value that
they created the young researchers
realized that Arthur Rock was right they
agreed to his suggestion so he got to
work but he hit a brick wall despite
being brilliant the eight researchers
had no profile of their own and they
were working with technology that may as
well have been magic to the average
person Arthur Rock approached 35
different investors and couldn't squeeze
a single Cent out of them on the advice
of a colleague he approached Sherman
Fairchild Fairchild was an inventor and
Keen student of science he was also very
rich Sherman's father was the co-founder
and first chairman of IBM and when he
passed away in 1924 Sherman was the sole
inheritor of his multi-million dollar
estate as well as millions of dollars
worth of IBM stock Fairchild met with
the eight researchers one of them
presented his vision for the future of
semiconductors the substrate should be
made from Silicon not germanium he
argued silicon had Superior physical
properties plus its materials were
cheaper to obtain the Visionary
researcher also expressed his belief
that appliances made from Silicon
components would simply be replaced
rather than repaired which meant more
money for someone like Sherman Fairchild
the businessman was impressed enough to
invest he agreed to loan the researchers
one and a half million dollars to start
their company in return he'd gained the
right to buy the whole company for 3
million an option he ended up exercising
the eight young men the so-called
traitorous 8 founded Fairchild
Semiconductor in 1957. two of the eight
would go on to become main characters in
the Intel Story one of them Robert Noyes
made the presentation that persuaded
Sherman Fairchild to invest Noyes
invented the modern integrated circuit
which essentially was the blueprint for
implementing transistors in a silicon
substrate Gordon Moore meanwhile was
such a brilliant scientist that he
coined a term still in common use in
modern Computing today Moore's Law he
was also the man who hired Andy Grove to
come work at Fairchild it was 1963 Moore
and his colleagues needed smart
employees who could lead the lab's
research into embedding trans resistors
on Silicon Wafers Andy had just finished
his PhD it was the beginning of a
30-year working relationship that would
transform the futures of all three men
the future of Silicon Valley and the
future of computing Andy quickly made a
name for himself as a high achiever with
high standards the group he was part of
was trying to tackle a persistent
problem that when it was solved would
pave the way for metal oxide
semiconductor technology which is still
the most common type of transistor in
integrated circuits more than 50 years
later his team also succeeded in
reducing the instability of transistors
by removing impurities in Silicon ships
Bob noyce and Gordon Moore were watching
closely Fairchild semiconductor enjoyed
a great first decade they were
technologically Innovative but they were
also Innovative on the business side of
things in 1965 they shocked the industry
by announcing they would price their
integrated circuit products at just one
dollar far below cost Bob noyce drove
that decision because he understood that
the market for integrated circuits was
about to explode setting the price so
low allowed Fairchild to achieve two
important things firstly it would
accelerate demand secondly below cost
pricing would make Fairchild The Logical
choice for companies just entering the
market the Insight reminds me of one of
the big realizations that Morris Chang
the founder of tsmc made early on in his
own career when Morris was at Texas
Instruments he implemented learning
curve pricing a model that improved
yields by rapidly scaling production at
low price he understood that when
manufacturing volumes are small data and
market share are more important than
profits because as the market matures
the profits will come you've just got to
give yourself the biggest chance of
being the guy standing underneath the
waterfall when they do this is the kind
of Freedom that senior staff at
Fairchild had they pushed boundaries and
sold technology to clients as big as the
American Military and as far as Andy and
the Traders 8 were concerned there was
just one problem the structure of their
deal with Sherman Fairchild meant they
didn't have any Equity Gordon Moore and
Bob Noyes believe their talents were
being undervalued they also believed
that they could take Research into
computer memory in exciting New
Directions a highly simplified model of
a computer today includes three main
parts the CPU which acts as the main
processor there's RAM for short-term
memory and hard drives or ssds to store
long-term memory at the time the late
60s long-term memory lived on magnetic
discs not silicon semiconductors
short-term memory didn't exist at all
neither did the CPU there was basically
no demarcation between software and
Hardware more and noise didn't
necessarily see every piece of the
puzzle but they believed they could
marry silicon semiconductor technology
with computer memory and they were
determined to figure it out so they
decided to speak to Arthur Rock rocket
learned from the experience of founding
Fairchild semiconductor he could see
that while it was a great model for
making new discoveries it only made one
person seriously Rich Sherman Fairchild
Rock knew that there had to be a better
way to reward successful Founders so he
suggested to more noise that they start
a company and he would lead the
fundraising they agreed and rock ended
up raising two and a half million
dollars his reward in addition to an
equity stake was being appointed the
inaugural chairman on July 18 1968 the
new company was founded in Mountain View
it needed a name more and noise
initially thought they would go by the
convention of the time that would have
meant calling the company more noise but
yeah that's a terrible name it sounds
like more noise it's not ideal so they
went back to the drawing board they
picked a new name integrated Electronics
chances are you know the shortened
version of this name Intel now that they
had their name decided Gordon Moore and
Bob Noyes turned their attention to
recruitment they both knew there was
only one choice for Intel's first ever
employee the young man who had survived
a fascist dictatorship German military
occupation the siege of Budapest
communism and a brutal Crackdown before
finding his new home in the United
States Andy Grove you might think that
given the amount of adversity he had
already survived and the huge promise he
had already shown in the early part of
his career that Andy would be confident
about his ability to take the next step
but that's not how he saw it Andy was to
use his own words scared to death he had
left a secure job in an Innovative
company to run r d for a new startup in
an industry that essentially didn't
exist yet but he had complete faith in
what the founders were trying to do Bob
Noyes and Gordon Moore were in a hurry
the conglomerate Honeywell was ready to
buy 64-bit static Random Access Memory
chips from any company that successfully
developed them that triggered a rush
among memory manufacturers intel was at
the back of the pack it had only been
around for a year it hadn't released a
single product and it was also
establishing semiconductor manufacturing
capacity essentially from scratch but
Intel's Founders Bob Noyes and Gordon
Moore believed that they could overtake
their competitors from behind by
developing faster and more powerful
memory products so they directed Andy to
pursue three different Technologies at
once the first was bipolar memory this
approach to use relatively proven
technology the bipolar transistor but it
was hard to develop further the second
was silicon gate metal oxide
semiconductor memory and the third was
multi-chip memory which involved linking
together smaller memory ships whichever
technology proved its viability the
fastest would become Intel's first
product the winner was bipolar memory as
a result Intel's first ever product was
the 3101 the 3101 was a static random
access memory chip or SRAM srams were
hard to develop and intel was working on
extremely tight deadlines but the 3101
was still twice as fast as the
competition its development sent a clear
signal to the rest of the industry intel
was a force to be reckoned with to
underline this it quickly followed up
the 3101 with the 1101 developed in
parallel with a 3101 the 1101 was also
an SRAM chip but it was also the first
widely produced chip made using silicon
gate metal oxide semiconductor
technology MOS technology was a much
more efficient way of manufacturing
chips than the bipolar memory
architecture it replaced it enabled the
large-scale integration that would be
required for the PC Revolution if the
1101 was a big step forward then Intel's
next product was a huge leap released in
October of 1970 the 1103 was the first
Dynamic random access memory chip it
made magnetic core memory completely
obsolete the device you're watching this
video on is almost certainly packed with
dram chips they're the memory of choice
when you want something with low cost
and high capacity the 1103 made Intel a
world leader in memory manufacturing for
a decade Bob Noyes and Gordon Moore
capitalized on this incredible early
success by taking Intel public at a
market cap of 58 million dollars in
October of 1971. their company had gone
from nothing to being the market leader
in just two and a half years and they
weren't done yet just Weeks Later Intel
unveiled the world's first widely
available microprocessor the 4004 the
40o4 is a great example of how the
product that make the biggest impact
require a combination of Brilliance and
Circumstance when a Japanese calculator
manufacturer asked Intel to design chips
for a series of calculators Intel
assigned its engineer Ted Hoff to the
project during his search for a
cost-effective design Hof devised the
plan of fitting a CPU onto a single chip
by successfully harnessing MOS
technology Intel's Engineers fit twice
as many transistors onto the 4004 as
existing products which resulted in five
times the operating speed the 4004 was
as powerful as the eniac the first ever
programmable digital computer but it was
a bit smaller eniac weighed 27 tons and
was as big as a house the 4004 by
contrast measured 1 8 by 1 6 of an inch
by miniaturizing the CPU the 40o4 made
it possible for small machines to
perform the kinds of calculations that
in the past only mainframe computers
could do in other words it made the
personal computer possible Intel
released four transformational products
within the first four years of its
history and it did all of this with
fewer than 200 staff Intel followed up
the 4004 with the ad08 the first 8-bit
microprocessor the seeds of the PC
revolution had been sewn they would soon
bear fruit the March 1974 issue of a
magazine featured the first ever ad for
a personal computer the Selby short for
scientific electronic and biological the
Selby cost 565 dollars and it came with
1K of programmable memory with an
additional 15K of memory available for
two thousand seven hundred and sixty
dollars it ran on an 8008 microprocessor
made by Intel next in July came the Mark
8 which also ran on an 8080. the 8080
was a critical component of all the
first personal computers but Intel's
Founders and Engineers were already
looking Beyond it between the release of
the Selby and the Mark 8 it released the
8080 the 8080 was the first truly
general purpose microprocessor it was a
computer on a chip and at time when
conventional computers cost thousands of
dollars Intel sold it for just 360
dollars at release the 8080 soon became
the industry standard cementing Intel
status as Undisputed market leader the
next noteworthy personal computer to be
released was the Altair 8800 designed
and manufactured by mits it made it to
the market just before Christmas of
1975. it was billed as the world's first
mini computer kit to rival commercial
models the Altair shipped with an Intel
8080 CPU and a 256 byte Ram card all for
four hundred dollars you had to assemble
it yourself but it was cheap and
accessible and you could write and
execute your own software two Harvard
freshmen realized that the Altair
created new possibilities they contacted
Ed Roberts founder of mits the company
that made the Altair within six weeks
the two Intrepid young programmers had
compiled a version of basic to run on
the Altair their names were Paul Allen
and Bill Gates and the company they
would soon establish they named it
Microsoft which of course was go on to
become an important part of the Intel
story that same year a young Steve
Wozniak partly inspired by the Altair
built a microprocessor into his video
terminal in order to develop a complete
computer that project became the apple
one and Steve wozniak's close friend
Steve Jobs convinced him that the two
should go into business together intel
was growing as quickly as the number of
transistors it could fit onto its memory
chips in 1978 it introduced the 8086
signaling the beginning of the famous
x86 architecture in the early days Bob
noyce Gordon Moore and Andy Grove opted
for informal weekly luncheons with their
direct reports that system worked great
when Intel had 200 employees but by 1980
Intel had 15 000 and a market cap of 2
billion dollars such rapid growth
required a more scalable management
approach so Intel's Founders implemented
a program that emphasized openness while
also delegating decision making to the
lowest levels they trusted staff to
solve problems and to prove they were
all in it together they avoided luxuries
like limo long lunches Intel Rose to the
top of the industry and stayed there
because it maintained focus on the micro
and the macro at the same time it was
helped by Andy Grove's paranoia now Andy
wasn't paranoid in the same way as Bill
Shockley he was paranoid in a way that
kept him Vigilant Andy would go on to
write a book about his time at Intel in
it he wrote that success breeds
complacency complacency breeds failure
only the paranoids survive the title of
the book was borrowed from this final
sentence as a result of his productive
paranoia Andy urged his senior
Executives to allow people to test new
ideas products and sales channels when
the world changed he was determined to
be ready on August 12 1981 IBM unveiled
the model 5150 this product set the
standard for what we think of now when
we think about PCS helped by a famous
marketing campaign the IBM PC flew off
the shelves the company originally
forecast that it would sell 250 000
units within five years in reality could
sometimes ship that many in a single
month it became the first computer
widely adopted by regular businesses and
every single one had an Intel
microprocessor Inside by bringing the
personal computer into hundreds of
thousands of homes and offices around
America IBM created a vast ecosystem of
software and other peripherals in
December of 1982 flush with the money
that the PC was generating IBM paid 250
million dollars for a 12 share of Intel
the next year Intel's revenues exceeded
one billion dollars for the first time
the leadership team celebrated the first
250 million dollar Revenue quarter with
a rare Indulgence a custom bottled
champagne they called vintage Intel
that's not to say there weren't bumps
along the road Intel's first attempt at
a 32-bit processor system the iapx 432
was a radical departure in terms of
build and purpose than the 808 and the
8080 processor instead it was a disaster
running 5 to 10 times more slowly than
competitors but Gordon Andy and Bob knew
that occasional failures were just the
cost of creating a culture that reliably
produced transformational products it's
seemed like nothing could stop Intel but
the story was never going to be that
simple because in business your margin
is always someone else's opportunity if
you want to build an enduring business
you need a moat that will allow you to
maintain a competitive advantage against
Rivals and there are a few ways to build
a mode you can exploit some regulation
in a way that no one else has you can be
handed a monopoly by the government so
you're the only game in town or you can
make a product that no one else can the
problem with that approach is that
unless you can keep finding ways to
protect your moat someone will
eventually get through and that's what
happened to Intel it pioneered memory
chips and scaled their production but in
the process it also taught other
companies how to make them every
computer needed memory but memory is
just memory so long as it was delivered
on time and on budget the companies who
needed it didn't care much where it came
from Intel's Rivals were learning how to
make dram chips they were after a big
piece of the market that Intel had
created and they could see
vulnerabilities the main one was
manufacturing Intel had been played by
intermittent under capacity issues for
years Intel's seventh Fab took two years
to get up to full capacity things
weren't helped by an economic slowdown
which further undermined its
manufacturing capabilities as a result
the companies that bought Intel's
products started asking it to Outsource
some of its production to other
suppliers a practice known as secondary
sourcing Intel partnered with
up-and-coming Japanese firms that took
some of the pressure off but it also
helped Japanese firms like Toshiba NEC
Hitachi Mitsubishi electronic and
Fujitsu climb up the learning curve
learning how Intel designed their memory
chips was the first big Advantage for
the Japanese companies their second big
Advantage was their Superior access to
Capital every Japanese electronics
company that threatened Intel's Market
position was part of a conglomerate with
a presence in several Industries and a
close relationship to the Japanese
Banking and government sectors they
could borrow cheaply to expand their
production capacity and had access to
high quality engineering talent and they
could absorb Financial losses for a very
long time as a result the top Japanese
producers were able to reach production
yields that were up to 40 percent higher
than leading U.S companies at its peak
dram memory accounted for more than 90
percent of Intel's revenues it
subsidized other parts of the business
while also serving as a technology
driver that underpinned Intel's learning
curve but that was before Intel's mode
became a commodity and its secondary
suppliers became rivals in 1974 Intel
controlled 83 percent of the market for
drams 10 years later it controlled just
1.3 percent this was a shocking decrease
opinions about how to respond were
divided the engineers thought the sales
team needed to work harder the sales
team thought the engineers needed to
come up with better products everyone
was desperately looking to Intel's
leaders for an answer from having been
on top of the world Intel's Founders
were finally faced with the reality that
the business model that had carried them
to success making memory chips was no
longer an option
D-Day arrived in early 1985. Andy Grove
was in his office with Gordon Moore
pondering these men were already Legends
together with Bob Noyes they built their
company into the Undisputed market
leader in computer memory they could
have walked off into the sunset content
in the knowledge that their legacies and
personal fortunes were forever secure so
that's what they did Gordon Moore and
Andy Grove shook hands and walked in the
direction of the sunset except they
didn't get very far because after just a
few seconds they turned around and
walked back in and they rehired
themselves this whole exchange came
about because of a question Andy asked
Gordon if the board kicked us out and
brought in a new CEO what do you think
the new CEO would do in response to this
situation Moore looked him straight in
the eyes and answered his voice steady
they'd get us out of the memory business
so that's exactly what they vowed to do
Gordon Moore and Andy Grove symbolically
fired themselves from their positions as
Leaders of an industry incumbent which
had lost the agility to respond to a
rapidly changing world and then they
rehired themselves as Leaders of a
company that would become the world
leader in microprocessors with Newfound
tenacity microprocessors were by no
means an obviously attractive Revenue
Source personal computers were coming
into Focus as a business opportunity but
the outline was still fuzzy they didn't
have the luxury of working from a
blueprint and they didn't have the
luxury of colleagues who saw things the
same way they did internal resistance
was stiff intel was defined by memory it
was such a core product Intel's
employees including many of its top
Executives were emotionally attached to
the dram business and the company was
highly dependent on it the sales team
couldn't let go of the belief that they
just needed a full product line to do a
good job in front of customers but Andy
Grove understood the reality Intel had
to lose its memory or it would lose
everything the history of business is
littered with companies that were on top
for a long time but couldn't see how
fast the world was changing in ways that
threatened their position names like
Nokia Kodak and blackberry didn't mean
anything to Andy but we understand them
as cautionary tales of companies that
weren't paranoid enough to survive he
summarized this challenge better than
anyone one of the toughest challenges is
to make people see that these
self-evident truths are no longer true
there weren't and still aren't many
examples of a company the size of Intel
successfully pivoting away from the
business model that made it successful
in the first place but that's what Andy
was determined to do he directed the
head of Intel's memory division to
develop a plan to get out of the memory
business unsurprisingly this guy refused
the order so Andy fired him and ordered
his replacement to do the same thing get
out of the memory business the
replacement also refused so Andy had no
choice to fire him too I mean this is
kind of understandable no one wants to
make themselves obsolete especially when
it means firing the people you've worked
with for years but it was still brutal
it was brutal but it had to be done Andy
knew he was trying to turn around a huge
ship that was rapidly taking on water
Intel lost 107 23 million dollars in
1986 until 2022 it was the only year
that Intel had ever lost money it was
closing factories laying off thousands
of Staff it was headed for bankruptcy it
was in this climate of Doom and Gloom
where Intel wasn't just worried about
its future in the market for memory
chips but its continued existence as a
company that Andy took over the Reigns
as CEO from Gordon Moore but there was
no time to celebrate because Andy was
face to face with the biggest challenge
of his career he had a singular Focus to
do the obvious but hard thing it was a
huge task but there was one thing even
more dangerous than trying to execute
such an audacious pivot standing still
Intel's Founders and Engineers had done
more than any other company to create
the technology underpinning the personal
computer the speed at which Intel had
lost market share in memory took Andy by
surprise but he had an ace up his sleeve
since 1982 the company had been quietly
working on a new microprocessor called
the 3386 it wasn't just the next product
in the x86 architecture it was a
paradigm shift the 386 was the first
32-bit microprocessor technologically it
was like when tennis players switched
from using wooden rackets to ones made
of graphite it had four kilobytes of
memory and could perform 4 million
operations per second it could run more
than one program at a time and
critically it made graphical operating
environments for PCs practical Andy
Grove knew the 386 had potential to be
Intel's life raft so he wanted to
protect it at all costs after years of
resorting to secondary sourcing in order
to fulfill clients demands for memory
chips a decision which helped Intel's
Rivals overtake it and ultimately turned
Intel's main product line into a
commodity that almost anyone could
manufacture Andy was determined to make
Intel the sole gatekeeper he faced up to
his responsibility as a leader and made
the call Intel would not license the
design of the 386 to any other
manufacturers no more secondary sourcing
the best decisions are the ones that
seem totally obvious in hindsight but
Andy was taking a big risk he was
defying IBM which was Intel's biggest
customer and a major shareholder he was
also defying standard industry practice
secondary sourcing was common because
manufacturers consistently had to solve
difficult and novel problems technical
issues resulted in longer wait times for
clients so in order to guard against the
risk of intermittent Supply customers
insisted that their chips be made by
multiple manufacturers it wasn't an easy
decision nor was it a cheap one Andy and
his team had to spend billions on
expensive new Fabs to ensure consistent
Supply AMD one of Intel's secondary
suppliers for microprocessors
successfully sued for breach of contract
and ended up winning more than 10
million dollars in Damages but Andy
would be Vindicated his decision was key
to successfully turning around Intel and
his decision dated back to a project
that began when intel was on the edge of
disaster and to Andy's paranoia in March
of 1985 a new computer manufacturer
named compact started working on a new
desktop machine compact was fighting a
difficult battle the main player in the
market was IBM big blue but compact
wasn't working alone it worked closely
with Intel which shared information
about its 386 processor architecture and
they were also working closely with
Microsoft so Intel Compact and Microsoft
signed a non-disclosure agreement and
got to work early prototypes of the
computer that they were working on were
designed around the earliest batches of
the 386 which had a 12 megahertz clock
speed crucially by the time the computer
was ready for release manufacturing
yields of the improved 16 megahertz 386
had reached acceptable numbers resulting
in a 25 speed boost on September 9th
1986 Compaq unveiled The Desk Pro 386 at
a launch event in New York City The Desk
Pro 386 was the most advanced high
performance personal computer in the
world and it was a hit by the following
February compact had sold 25 units
during the second quarter of the Year
another ninety thousand were sold Compaq
reported selling out of the dusk Pro 386
by the end of 1987. not bad for a
computer that cost six thousand five
hundred dollars The Desk Pro had
successfully challenged the big blue
compact's president was quoted at the
time saying that IBM had six months to
respond or they risked losing some of
their market share that had been
unchallenged since the introduction of
the model 5150 IBM's response the PS2
didn't come on the market until almost a
whole year later and when it did it was
a total disaster IBM planned to replace
Microsoft's popular dos operating system
with its own os2 but this proved to be a
big mistake however the failure of the
PS2 which lost millions of dollars and
sent the entire company into a tailspin
effectively left Microsoft without any
viable competitors Bill Gates had this
to say when asked about the success of
the desk Pro in an interview for PC
Magazine in 1997. the folks at IBM
didn't trust the 386. they didn't think
it would get done so we encourage
compact to go ahead and just do a 386
machine that was the first time people
started to get a sense that it wasn't
just IBM setting the standards that this
industry had a life of its own and that
companies like Compact and Intel were in
there doing new things that people
should pay attention to IBM still stung
by Andy Grove's decision to not Second
Source production of the 386 fell victim
to the same kind of thinking he spent so
long trying to overcome it had a
stubborn irrational belief that Intel
couldn't get it done the desk Pro
established Intel's 386 processor as the
dominant CPU Choice it's possible to
tell the story from this point on like
it's just one big Victory lap for Intel
but there were still significant
challenges that required all of Andy's
technical business and managerial
expertise to solve the first one arrived
almost right away when Intel began work
on a chip that would succeed the 386. at
the time there was a strong push within
the semiconductor industry toward a
protocol called reduced instruction set
computing risk this design eliminated
rarely used instructions in order to
free up space and boost speed although
it's retroactively been called complex
instruction set architecture Sisk the
incumbent protocol didn't really have a
name it was just how things were done in
this design a single instruction
performs all loading evaluating and
storing operations hence it's complex
many smart people within Intel were
convinced that risk was the future one
of the Intel's Rising Stars a 25 year
old engineer named Pat gelsinger
actually quit because he thought the
company was going to move away from the
Sisk architecture he believed that what
risk chips gained in speed they lost in
flexibility more to the point they
weren't compatible with the software
already on the market the same software
that Intel believed would guarantee the
success of the follow-up to the 386.
Andy Grove shared the young Engineers
doubts he also wanted to keep him on
staff so he put gelsinger in charge of
the follow-up project the 486 the 486
which was designed use using the Sisk
architecture was released in 1989 it
doubled the performance of the 386
without increasing the clock rate
cementing Intel's technological
advantage and leading Market position
and today Pat gelsinger serves as CEO of
Intel of course Andy wasn't the kind of
guy to put all his eggs into one basket
Intel also released a risk chip the 860
but it was the 486 that would emerge as
the preferred option for buyers it took
until March 1991 more than five years
after the release of the Intel 386 for
AMD to release its own am386 processor
partly that was because of Intel's
success tying it up in the courts the
relationship between the two
semiconductor companies had become
acrimonious amd's processor was arguably
the superior product but Intel won the
race to be first to Market with a
product that met the surging demand for
personal computer processors the success
of the 386 and the 486 allowed Andy and
his team to plow massive sums of money
into creating new and faster designs
testing the limit bits of the law coined
by its founder Gordon Moore it also gave
them the money to launch one of the most
brilliant marketing campaigns of all
time
[Music]
sound logo Intel created as part of its
Intel Inside campaign it was the perfect
campaign launched at the perfect time
Intel could see that PCS were about to
become an essential device so it sought
to bolster consumer interest and demand
for computers that featured Intel inside
this is kind of crazy most people knew
nothing about computers let alone the
components inside them but they
identified their computer by the type of
Chip it had inside not just by who made
the Box Intel Inside wasn't just aimed
at consumers though Intel understood
that its positive brand recognition gave
it huge leverage over PC manufacturers
like compact Dell and even IBM so it
would offer to pay for half of the
manufacturer's marketing costs for their
new computer if they prominently
advertise the Intel processor inside the
machine the results were astronomical
Intel's annual net income topped 1
billion dollars for the first time in
1992 and they made almost 6 billion in
Revenue that year by this stage Intel
had created a rock solid partnership
with Microsoft every PC with an Intel
processor shipped with Windows as
standard many people believed this was
anti-competitive and that it undermined
Innovation whether or not it was good
for consumers it was certainly good for
Intel the partnership between the two
companies became known as Wintel in 1993
helped by the release of their fifth
generation Pentium processor Intel's
revenues increased by more than 50
percent to over eight billion dollars
using the massive proceeds of its x86
series sales Andy and his team continued
developing increasingly powerful
processors and all the while the money
pile just grew bigger revenues broke 20
billion in 1996 and over 5 billion of
that was profit the 90s was the decade
of Intel and Microsoft both effectively
became monopolists for millions of
people around the world a good computer
had Microsoft Windows and an Intel
processor both companies knew this and
they knew they could charge accordingly
in May of 1998 11 years after being made
CEO following Gordon Moore's retirement
Andy Grove stepped down he drove Intel's
transformation from a maker of memory
chips into the world's dominant producer
of PC microprocessors servers and
general purpose Computing during his
tenure Intel's market cap Grew From 4
billion to 197 billion revenues grew
more than 10x when Andy stepped down
intel was the world's seventh biggest
company and employed 64 000 people Time
magazine named him their man of the year
he continued serving as Intel's chairman
until 2004 when he finally retired
Andros IST Von Groff passed away in
March of 2016 at the age of 79. by that
time Intel had lost its status as the
world's preeminent semiconductor
manufacturer in the face of competition
unlike anything it had seen for decades
can Intel ever win back its Crown that's
a story for another day but the story of
Andy Grove a Jewish kid born in Budapest
in 1936 who lived through a fascist
dictatorship Nazi occupation and the
final solution escaped repressive
communism and built one of the world's
greatest companies that's story deserves
to be told for centuries to come thanks
for watching